dann muss man noch mal drücken dann
gehen den ferien modus und paaren sich
zusammen mit meinem iphone und heraus
kommt ein
der airport war nicht so witzig nicht
[Musik]
nachmachen übrigens leute tut mir leid
leider war in der ersten aufnahme das
mikrofon irgendwie leicht verwirrt also
es war auf jeden fall an es hat aber
nicht aufgenommen
woran das liegt weiß ich bis heute nicht
ich wollte das jetzt einfach bisher nach
synchronisieren da das ganze video schon
abgedreht ist ich die verpackung auch
schon weggeschmissen habe und würde mal
sagen erster versuch nach
synchronisation let's go leute was geht
ab und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen airport video geil alter ich freue
mich richtig endlich wieder hier neue na
ja wie soll ich mal sagen er sei
airports zu testen
ich war nämlich bei verschiedenen läden
ihr schreibt mir immer jo alexej die
airports ausziehen weil die airports aus
mein opa der airports von dem niveau der
tote er trotzdem ich danke euch in die
halle gefunden und dann habe ich gedacht
da überlege jetzt bin ich schon raus ich
weiß nicht was hier gesagt habe auf
jeden fall bin ich zu real gefahren auf
euren tipp und sollte dort airports oder
so ein airport verkaufen habe auch die
verkäufer gefragt die meinten die haben
aber keine so richtige facts wie ich
haben heute sondern nur sowas
und dann habe ich gedacht eigentlich
ganz interessant 12 eur 99 kannst du ja
mal mitnehmen so ist halt ähnlich wie
dieses kick dingen da ist hier muss
jetzt mal kurz pausieren leute ich hatte
ja schon mal so ein airport ersatz von
kik auch mit seiner band war grausam
und ja okay jetzt geht es weiter hier
habe ich nämlich darauf aufmerksam macht
kann man die teile die ich für 12 990
bekommt zum internet nur für 30 euro 85
oder was das war und dadurch habe ich
einen schlag gemacht
interessant war wirklich höchst
interessant und mehr muss ich eigentlich
auch gar nicht mehr sagen ich würde
sagen ich hoffe wir haben gleich wieder
tun und können dann ganz bequem das
video schauen
mein modell aus sicht der hatte hieß kh
3001 von der marke telefunken gibt es
allerdings wirklich nur bei real und
irgendwo im internet
und jetzt haben wir wieder okay leute
ich hoffe ihr nämlich wenn ich liebe
instagram alex wie let's go vogel
ausgepackt modell heißt übrigens tele
punkten
3000 1b stereo ohrhörer mit mikrofon
also die können genau das gleiche was
airports auch können und wir schauen mal
ob die soundkulisse ist als bei unseren
bisherigen favoriten die 1000 events für
30 euro gibt sie im internet also so
ganz kommt so nicht ans original aber
sind wir haben auf jeden fall eine
proportionale steigerung dahin sage ich
mal so macht es sinn ja hier kann man
das schon mal sehen mehr haben wir noch
nicht daran glaube ich als heute oder
und vom sound her kann ich aber
weiterhin sagen das ist bis jetzt auf
jeden fall die beste kopiert kann ich
auch jedem empfehlen wenn ihr sowas
sucht dann kauft euch die auch
vielleicht überzeugen die mich jetzt
noch mehr dann ändere ich meine meinung
sagt beschreibung ach so gern wir haben
wieder ein band hätte ich mir auch
denken können
das ist natürlich wieder mit band
[Applaus]
[Musik]
weit bist das fühlt sich richtig komisch
an
denn die seien ja auch raus oder jetzt
hat es dafür bei den kritikern habe ich
irgendwie den fehler gemacht habe ich
diese schnur hier vorne und habe gar
nicht gereicht dass man das ja auch
einfach umdrehen kann
es war ein bisschen dumm ich bin halt
manchmal sieht das bruders fonds seien
absolut schon jetzt zum absolut scheiße
habe ich mir schon fast gedacht ich
verstehe dich aber auch ich habe ich
fast gar nicht so
und meine stimme klingt für mich gerade
als wäre ich irgendwie im sommer
komischen frequenz verrückt naja gut
machen wir erstmal ab wie sonntag da
jetzt hier
wir haben jede beschreibung dickes buch
ich finde du auf mich für 12 990 wirkt
das eigentlich ganz neues also könnte
schlimmer sein
die brauchen wir erstmal nicht hier
haben wir noch was ist das
durch stoppschilder für die man auf
ziehen kann aber da sind auch schon
drauf oder er wird hatte ich das nicht
gerade so drin
hier schon irgendwie drin dass das recht
sein muss das ist komplett falsch aus
die recht falsch aus oder ist so wie es
gerade passt auch viel besser
ich würde sagen wir checken direkt
eigentlich schon die soundqualität
verbinden die mal eben mit meinem handy
und ich schauen wir kurz nach wie das
geht
vor der ersten positiven aufnahme 1234
könnte es sein dass ich die erste
aufnahmen muss sechseinhalb stunden
später ja ich kann mir wirklich ein
andermal diesem kam
ich habe die auf jeden fall gerade
aufgeladen weil die waren wie leer und
jetzt habe ich mich schon connected das
ging relativ leicht man musste einmal
auf diesen knopf drücken dann gingen die
an
da muss man nochmal drüber gehen den
perry modus und haaren sich zusammen mit
meinem iphone und heraus kommt ein
er hat
gar nicht so mit sich ok also ich bin
connectiv meiner kurzen soundcheck net
ich bin jetzt wirklich das ist für mich
zurzeit immer so eine spannende sache
also wenn mich jemand fragt wo alex was
ist gerade so eigentlich bei mir im
leben das spannendste sagt ja ich sitze
da manchmal dann und testen war airports
und bin dann immer richtig gespannt auf
die soundqualität
das hört man heute macht irgendwie so
ein bisschen deutsch rap oder so mal
copacabana ich in deutsche und du sagst
copacabana
[Musik]
ich würze ehrliches also wenn ich die
jetzt für diesen kick den vergleiche die
von kicker und zähler gekostet die haben
jetzt 12 990 gekostet also 13 euro sagen
wir mal das ist echt gut ich hoffe hier
ist es meist sonnig wird es mal
probieren was du sagst du drin ja okay
leute juli ist jetzt auch gut dran wo
kritischer blick ja jetzt für die musik
copacabana ja besser na ja besser aber
ich finde das design ist halt scheiße ja
diese stürze scheiße dieses band auch
das kann man fast gar nicht also ja gut
meinte die funktionieren dann kannst du
es nicht ab macht das band sind die
damit muss alles anders ich glaube schon
so ich kann es mal durchschneidung wir
gucken gleich was passiert dahin ist ja
noch verlosen ja auch gut kommen haben
wir heute an nächsten verlosung was wir
machen immer durchschneiden kommt immer
mal große mikrofon test und das ist auch
mit mikrofon jemand konzerts immer
wieder
ja hallo
doch damals fand scheiße das gespräch
habe ich aufgelegt
ja das geht die qualität von mikrofon
ist nicht so gut gestern war sie besser
gut das ist google aber mikrofon des
tanzes ist nicht gut alexander bekommt
das ist doch micro nicht so aber man
versteht ich trotzdem also ich kann doch
bei den airports manchmal dass nico echt
scheiße also alles gut
ich habe jetzt fahrt musik laufen
[Musik]
nicht namen übrigens gehe ich glaube
hier man jetzt hat das war es glaube ich
schon
eigentlich schade er gut aber das band
[ __ ] brutale ab so das ist das einzige
was daran echt scheiße ist ich glaube
die sind jetzt defekt des gipfels ein
bisschen hält in den kommentaren aber
wie verkauft man denn dieses scheiß band
ja wahrscheinlich ist da halt irgendwie
der bluetooth denn da drin damit
chrysler nicht auf keinen fall
ich werde auch nicht wofür wir uns
braucht die sind halt da irgendwie per
kabel verbunden meiste aber die sind in
der tat jetzt hier von der bildfläche
verschwunden
also party hier wird immer gehabt das
war's mit dem kh 3001 b aber von der
sound quali hier bis jetzt finde ich
klar die 1000er zwar noch ein bisschen
besser aber gar nicht mal schlecht für
2099 ich bin mir da unsicher auf die
überall so günstig war aber hab ich
heute irgendwie aus versehen ein angebot
bekommen habt ganz klar trotzdem
interessantes produkt kann ich empfehlen
ihr könnt mir gerne weitere schicken ich
suche immer noch diesen lidl dinge an
falls ihr zuhause hat schick weniger
bitte oder action oder airports pro die
branche auch noch leute das war's aber
nicht main kanal blogger aktivieren
instagram alex w da werden wir jetzt
natürlich heute ausnahmsweise mal nicht
viel los aber da werden aber andere
sachen verlost deswegen lohnt es sich da
zu folgen das war's haut rein
wir sehen uns morgen um 9 zu wieder ciao
[Musik]